pas
on était partis pour les vacances en
afrique on s'est retrouvés et touré sur
l'antarctique
on avait la fina billet sur un string
pour nous car on s'est mis en smoking et
ils ont la fin de nos peines greentree
faut venir si c'était pas évident les
eskimos sont pas et nous on claque des
dents on ad'abord sympathisé avec l'ours
blanc mais c'était pas facile il fallait
freiner ses élans et si ça vous arrange
je vous présente un manchot c'est pour
vous cette guinée vous irez plus serré
afin qu'ils parlent wheels a fait trois
grands volets c'est pour vous ayez
s'ébaubir être gérées afin que de paris
ne savait trop gros et les cds kibo
les nus de blizzard on organise des
soirées bardot et que ce sont souvent
les invités petit à petit notre vie
c'est bien natale et on a vite appris à
chasser et à pêcher à tuer repas
commence détecte baleine
cette répartition mais on en plus en eau
guen même les cieux que l'on refuse ou
tirer paraît qu'à cause de nous les
routes sont défoncées
mais c'est plus des pingouins des
mammouths d'ailleurs mammouth mais quand
maman pis c'est pour vos séries
ces gorilles est gérée à fargues et de
paris ne savait trop à combler ce fossé
qui s'est brouillée l'affiché ré
attaquer demain luis avait trois élèves
continuent toujours de screamo dommage
amène des sous titres inédits
ce qui est bien au pôle nord c'est
qu'ils connaissent pas la crise quand on
a besoin d'argent on passe à la banquise
sur un gel de la louer à l'igloo meyrin
qu'on a bâtie toutes les deux de nos
propres mains
le manchot là ça y est nous ont pas
donné un coup de main
pourtant depuis six mois comprend des
balles dans la glace on aurait envie
d'un plongeon aux bahamas
on va lui demander de nous construire un
avion faut partir avant d'être
transformée en glace on pourquoi canada
parce que c'est ma mère ma cabane au
canada c'est vous saisissez vous irez
plus serré afoc et de ben oui ça fait 3
2 les c'est vous c'est guéri c'est le
rêve qui gérait un paquet de ballerines
savait pas drôle et c'est bon